president biden wants to keep the focus
on his agenda not the former president's
trial cbs evening news anchor and
managing editor norah o'donnell
spoke with president biden in his first
network television interview since
taking office
he talked about covet relief sanctions
on iran and his return
to the white house as president mr
president you've certainly been around
the white house for a long time
you've walked into the oval office you
were vice president for eight years but
did it feel a little different
when you walked in as president of the
united states and sat down on the other
side of the resolute desk
um you know what i felt different when
i walked through the front doors of the
white house
um after being sworn in there was that
picture of you
embracing yeah the first lady yeah you
know uh
president clinton i used to talk about
how who who's read the most biographies
of presidents
he's probably read more than i but i've
read a lot of them and i've always
thought about presidents in terms of
abraham lincoln up there or you know
franklin roosevelt or
george washington and i thought to
myself how in god's name
could i you know do comparison up to
them
but then i realized i know eight
presents i've served with a
term i know them they're all really fine
men
and it sort of brought it back down to
life-size
and you know their strengths and their
weaknesses in it
and it gave a little more of well you
know no i
don't get me wrong i think it's an
incredibly
challenging job and i'm extremely
flattered to have a chance to do it
and i hope to god i live up to it but it
seemed to make it more life-sized
and nora o'donnell joins us from
washington nora good morning
you've interviewed uh joe biden over the
years many times
but never when he was president of the
united states this is the first time as
sitting president
what stood out to you what felt
different if anything well i think
president biden now
realizes and feels the weight of being a
wartime president
um you know i said something like you've
been in office for two and a half weeks
and he said it feels a lot longer than
that
you know i think there's this sense of
really wanting to crush the coronavirus
uh the world's problems that exist up
there i mean he would say they're trying
to clean up from the
the past administration and so that's
all part of
what this white house is dealing with
and you know
already this week right they're going to
try and lay out school guidelines to
the cdc to get kids back in school
uh they are trying to encourage moderna
and pfizer to
ramp up productions i've learned from
sources close to the white house that
the president
is going to in the coming weeks visit
either the moderna production or pfizer
facilities in order to get a sense of
that and so they're really trying to
project this idea of a
competent president who's trying to push
forward on this and of course this week
they're going to
move forward on their own policy track
while the senate is going forward on the
impeachment track
on the coveted front talking about
schools as you mentioned
he said that the cdc will release
requirements to reopen schools perhaps
as soon as wednesday
any sense of what's and he talked
specifically about reopening them
safely he paused to say that word what
do we know what safely is likely to mean
well he's talking about getting teachers
vaccinated although not a requirement
he's talking about ventilation systems
and social distancing and masks
in classrooms but look you have
democratic
mayors at odds with teachers unions
in cities like chicago san francisco and
other places
um and so i think the question has been
you know mike bloomberg the former mayor
of new york has said it's time for
president biden to stand up to the
teachers unions and the teachers
and get them back to school it was
something i asked
the president about you'll hear his
answer tonight on the evening news
but there's clearly a sense that there
needs to be some leadership from the
white house some leadership some science
guidelines from the cdc you see the
chicago they've reached a deal they're
waiting for those guidelines from the
cdc that that could be the next step
how do we do this safely can someone
please tell us what we need to do
and so that's what's coming this week
and so there'll be i think a lot of news
um from the white house
on that front because school is of
course a top issue and as the president
acknowledged in that interview
the fact that kids are not in school
some 20 million kids that means a lot of
women
are dropping out of the workforce and
the president acknowledged this is a
national
emergency well norah congrats on the
interview i know you only had 20 minutes
with the president but you covered a lot
of topics i'm curious if
you got around to asking him about
hunter biden's book a lot of
eyebrows are being raised it's called
beautiful things talking about his
battle with drug addiction
people are wondering about the timing of
the book considering his dad just got in
the white house
did you get a chance to ask the
president about that does he have any
thoughts
i did and we released that that clip
over the weekend you know he said i'm
very proud of my son
um i think he used the phrase he's back
he got very emotional
the book is in many ways not only about
dealing with his
the loss of his brother beau from brain
cancer
but also about his own personal struggle
with addiction and recovery
and so it's a very personal memoir and
as the president said i don't
he said i don't know no one family in
america that doesn't have someone in
their own family or knows someone
you know the book was coming out did he
know the book was coming out
um either the president told me that he
did not know that the book
was coming out that he just learned
about it um recently and he
he had just gotten the galleys in the
last week all right norah
o'donnell thank you norah you can watch
more on nora's interview with president
biden tonight on the cbs evening news
when they'll discuss reopening schools
and we will be right back